today we're going to discuss the first
symptom that occurs with gallstones
over 80 percent of the time okay and I'm
also going to talk about the fastest way
to dissolve a gallstone if you have a
gallstone and let's dive right into the
first symptom that occurs over 80
percent of the time and that would be
asymptomatic that's right there's no
symptoms eighty percent of the time when
a person has gallstones right you don't
even know you have them unless they get
lodged into a duct where it creates
distension and pressure you might even
not know you have them until they get
really bad other than that are there any
other symptoms and yes there is
you're normally going to feel a
sensation underneath the right rib cage
kind of like a a fullness a tightness or
a pain you may feel pain in your right
rhomboid that muscle between your
scapula and the mid part of your spine
and the back part there you may even
have pain that runs up to this side of
your face right here these are all
indications that there's something going
on with the gallbladder it doesn't
necessarily have to be a stone it could
be very small micro stones that are
really hard to identify even on an MRI
you can also experience nausea
vomiting bloating belching jaundice now
why would you have jaundice like where
your skin is yellow well that's because
the gallstone is blocking the bowel duct
and we're getting a backup of bile into
the liver and that is coming out through
into the blood and into your skin
and some of that is something called
bilirubin which is kind of a byproduct
of your red blood cells and that can
create a yellowing effect of your skin
you may also notice that your urine is
darker than it should be yet your stool
is pale it's no longer dark brown now
let's talk about how to get rid of a
gallstone really quick it really is
important for you to understand what
causes a gallstone first and that will
explain everything many people think
gallstones come from consuming too much
fat fatty foods right or foods high in
cholesterol because a gallstone is made
out of cholesterol so just by knowing
that if you eat more cholesterol you're
at risk for getting a stone right well
actually no you're not the reason why
Stones develop
is for two reasons one is you have this
high amount of cholesterol coming
through the body and and this is the
most important thing you have a lack of
bile salts and this number two thing is
usually ignored they think it's just a
cholesterol but what keeps the
cholesterol thinned is the bile salts
bile is the primary mode of elimination
of cholesterol okay it goes to the bile
ducts the more bile you have the more
elimination of cholesterol that you have
so in reality you develop gallstones
because you don't have enough bile okay
and all of those symptoms that I
mentioned are really symptoms of a bile
deficiency you have this gallbladder
right it's not an extra organ that
you're developing you really need the
gallbladder testing to help you break
down the fats if you just put bile into
the small intestine without it being
concentrated you're not nearly going to
have the effect that you should to help
extract the fat soluble nutrients like
vitamin A d e K1 K2
omega-3 fatty acids things like that and
so this bile helps break down this fat
to a certain degree but then the
pancreas releases its enzyme called
lipase to help break it down even
smaller and so when you don't have a
gallbladder because they removed it now
you just have a tube from your liver to
the small intestine okay you don't get
any more concentration of the bile and
then you may have a hard time digesting
fats and absorbing these fat soluble
nutrients now on a rare occasion when
they do the surgery they might have made
this duct maybe a little bit too big and
now we get too much bile coming into the
small intestine and the biggest symptom
for that would be diarrhea and also not
enough bile is constipation and there's
another term I want to tell you about
it's called cholestasis and I think
that's a really common problem where you
don't have a stone it's kind of like
sludge so you have bio sludge it's a lot
of cholesterol but you don't have enough
bile and it kind it just sits there and
it causes a lot of pain and you do the
ultrasound you don't see any stone
there's also a syndrome that occurs
after you have your gallbladder removed
that you now have complications too and
I want to bring that up because
sometimes people will downplay that but
it can occur up to 40 percent of the
time and can you take a wild guess what
the biggest symptom is after surgery
cholestasis this bile sludge and that
can give you the same symptoms as you
had before you had the surgery with a
gallstone because they removed the stone
but they didn't remove the cause of the
stone which is the lack of bile problem
other risk factors for getting
gallstones would be pregnancy because
you have this spike in estrogen too much
estrogen can put you at risk for
gallstone also taking birth control
pills which is more estrogen obesity and
type 2 diabetes simply because
you can have higher levels of insulin
which also can aggravate and increase
the risk of gallstones liver disease can
put you at risk why because the liver
actually makes bile salts okay and the
more problems you have to deliver
whether it's fatty or liver disease
whatever the less bile you're going to
make constipation I already talked about
that that can put you at risk actually
just the bile deficiency can cause the
symptom of constipation and also if
you're low in folate okay this could be
more of a genetic problem or just you
don't consume any vegetables so you
don't get any folate
folate helps the conversion of
cholesterol to bile salts so people that
are on a Statin drug don't have the
cholesterol to make bile and a lot of
times they have a bile deficiency and
then they have all of these symptoms
also if you're on ppis these are
antacids that can create a big problem
or an increased risk of gallstones
simply because you need that ass in your
stomach to trigger the liver to release
bile salts a high carb diet which
increases insulin can also put you at
risk and even a low of fat diet can put
you at risk why because one of the
triggers for the release of bile is fat
and if you don't have enough like let's
say you're a vegetarian or a vegan that
could put you at risk for getting
gallstones so what is the solution what
do we do
this first solution is to take purified
biosols with some probiotic one with
meals and you take one an empty stomach
twice a day okay sometimes you need more
but you're going to take this over a
period of time what this is going to do
is going to help to dissolve the stone
because we have a situation where we
have a super concentrated amount of
cholesterol but not enough bile salt so
we need more bile salt realize that your
gut makes bile two so we really need to
also support the microbiome with some
probiotic and I think a really good way
to do that would be to consume like
sauerkraut or kimchi or even kefir
eating more salad be beneficial the
fiber in the salad helps to bind with
some of the cholesterol so that's one
cool thing also you're going to get
folate which will help you make this
conversion to make more bile I would
also manually massage underneath your
right rib cage and the left rib cage to
help maybe push some of the sludge
through and many times that will give
you a tremendous amount of relief and
the last thing to do is to decrease your
insulin okay because insulin can
increase your risk and you do that two
ways intermittent fasting and number two
going on a low carb diet and if you're
not familiar with that I put a link down
below but I think the most important
thing for you to watch now because
you're watching this video and you're
concerned about gallstones is to learn
how to do this manual flushing okay this
massage in your gallbladder and I put
that video up right here check it out